for more than half a century the french
have been turning the immense power of
the sea into clean electricity
this is laurence energy plant in
brittany a dam that holds back the tide
and forces it through giant turbines
that churn the water 124 turbine of the
the plant
20 meters below the surface were allowed
inside one that's been drained for
maintenance
the waters come from the sea over there
and
goes through to the estuary
the plant cost almost a billion pounds
in today's money but it generates enough
electricity for more than 200 000 people
it costs a lot to build such a
plant but as we use it for very for
decades maybe for centuries we will
get the money back
britain has the second strongest tide in
the world after canada peaking in the
bristol channel and the north west of
england the tidal power plants are still
on the drawing board seven of the most
promising could be built with the right
backing by 2030 producing enough
electricity for around four million
homes
the big attraction of harnessing the
ties is that they're predictable far
into the future not just how much the
water will rise and fall but how much
power can be generated like nuclear
tidal energy can help fill the gap when
the sun doesn't shine and the wind
doesn't blow
in liverpool there are plans for a tidal
power plant across the estuary of the
river mersey but the metro mayor says
the government is holding back unsure
about the technology the government just
needs to have confidence that the age of
tidal has come
not only would this project be great for
uk plc
but the development of the technology
itself and perhaps the modularization of
it means that we could export this
around the world creating jobs
the government's energy strategy only
mentioned tidal power plants or lagoons
in passing instead betting big on
nuclear this tidal engineer says it's a
big miss
your cost of a nuclear power station
could be typically four times the cost
of a large lagoon project
but your lagoon project will last 120
years
it doesn't have the problems of
long-term challenges of dealing with the
nuclear waste
the government says it is open to
considering tidal projects if they offer
value for money but advocates of marine
energy say the spike in fuel prices
makes reliable power from the sea
look even more attractive
thomas more sky news northern france